Seth Dillon the CEO of a satire website
comedy making fun of people both on the
left and the right who's got a lot of
heat lately with New York Times New York
Times wrote negative things about them
then they sued them the New York Times
had to change it it's pretty interesting
but let me read you some of the recent
articles that they've done the titles
you ready here we go
so Cracker Jack changes name to more
politically correct Caucasian Jack which
is pretty hilarious I've read three of
them I haven't read the 10. so there's
gonna be a reaction on the other ones
number two
Biden Cuts hole in masks so he can still
sniff people's hair pretty impressive by
the way that one's good three
motorcyclists who identifies as a
bicyclist set cycling world record that
is classic by the way David I love that
one four
CDC people with dirt on Clinton's have
843 percent greater risk of suicide
that's a pretty is that that's pretty
accuracy I think it is probably pretty
accurate right there five Fisher Price
releases my first peaceful protest
playset with house you can actually burn
down very thoughtful men identify and
identifying as a six-year-old crushes
game-winning Homer in t-ball
Championship I can go on by the way they
can go on and on and on and on and on
and obviously this is satire which we're
going to talk about here today but with
that being said thank you so much for
being a guest on valuetainment thanks
for having me glad to be here so satire
so satires it's very old I mean I think
this goes back to I was looking at the
history today
even back in Egypt 2000 years ago before
Christ they were doing satire and a lot
of it was making fun of people in power
it was church it was politicians it was
the government it was the rich people
it's not like it's one-sided it's been
continuous to hold people accountable
but this is your world tell us how you
got into this satire world
well uh The Babylon bee exists because
nobody was really doing satire from this
particular perspective at the time you
know you've heard you've probably heard
of The Onion right the onion is like
dropped off a little bit they used to be
the biggest they haven't uh yeah well
they've just been around for a long time
I mean we'll probably drop off by the
time we've been around for 30 years too
who knows hopefully not but you know
it's they've been around for a long time
started as a print publication they did
make they broke into the online world
and developed quite a bit of a following
but satire has been something that the
left the political left has used very
effectively to ridicule and mock their
ideological and political opponents on
the other side of the aisle
um you think of like the tonight shows
the late shows you know like the comedy
shows SNL's Weekend Update you go down
the list and all the people that are
doing that well including like in when
you get into uh uh the media World
cartoons like The Simpsons and Family
Guy and South Park you know that that
often delve into satire
um
it's being done well from their
perspective it wasn't really being done
that well or at all from the other side
of the aisle so our founder Adam Ford
started a website threw up like a
WordPress blog and started publishing
satire thought he he had a knack for it
and could do it well and wanted to do it
from another perspective the thing took
off went viral within a matter of a few
months we were generating millions of
page views he was doing a lot of church
chokes too inside Christian humor like
evangelicals yes he is yes are you
yourself as well I am myself but you're
still making fun of the church oh yeah
yeah yeah I mean give me an example of
it like like what's a satire joke
against the church
a satire joke against the church
um well I'll give you an example okay so
so like the guys I don't know if you're
familiar with like the different like
theological terms and stuff but like
there's a calvinist have you heard of
Calvinism of course you know kind of
this belief in like theological
determinism that God's predetermined who
he's going to save and what's going to
happen and all this stuff
um one of the one of the things I found
so refreshing when I met Adam uh for the
first time up in Michigan I was talking
about maybe acquiring the site from him
because he was wanting to sell it um
we're having a conversation and and it
came out to me in that conversation I
didn't know this that he was a calvinist
himself I'm like I'm actually surprised
by that because I've read these jokes on
your website making fun of Calvinists
like and I I'm escaping me like what the
specific headlines were I'd have to pull
them up to read them and I hate to botch
headlines like not read them correctly
but like there's a bunch of jokes on the
website that like that like uh just just
poke fun lightly at calvinist I'm like
it's very refreshing to me to see like
self-deprecating humor where you're
actually like confronting yourself in
your own ideas and he said you know
that's what that's what you want to do
with satire is you want to you know
obviously you want to truth to power
hold power accountable
you want to obviously attack bad ideas
when I try to like summarize our mission
statement I summarize as we ridicule bad
ideas that's what we do
but at the same time sometimes the ideas
on your side are bad or the behavior on
your side is bad and worth mockery and
ridicule and so I think it's a healthy
exercise to kind of hold your own ideas
why is New York Times pissed off with
you dude this is satire right why are
they upset with you guys
the New York Times uh they don't like
okay so so you I've said a moment ago
that the left is really good at this
stuff what they're not good at is
receiving it when you start firing back
it really bothers them they don't like
the jokes they don't think they're funny
so the New York Times has kind of jumped
onto this argument it's been going
around for a long time we had a uh years
ago probably three or almost four years
ago Brian stelter tweeted about us uh
you know he's a CNN personality and he
said
um at the bottom of all the shows at the
bottom of Don Lemon yeah yeah he said
the Babylon B is a fake news site they
call it satire and he put that in quotes
interesting and his point there is that
we're only pretending it being satire
we're like putting it on yeah and trying
to make people believe we're satire so
that we can write these stories that are
false that people will believe the New
York Times kind of picked that up and
ran with it and wrote a piece about us
they've actually written a couple about
us one of them that was kind of raising
the question of whether we're just
pretending to be a satire site and then
one of them actually said we are a and
I'm quoting them a far-right
misinformation site that sometimes
traffics and misinformation under the
guise of satire so it's this you know
devious malicious thing that they're
accusing us of doing where we pretend to
be satiris
um we objected strongly we're a satire
site no less than the onion we just have
a different political perspective
different theological perspective onion
is left onion would be concerned would
be on the left yeah yeah yeah so when
you see issues like a gun control or
abortion or whatever the issue is that
people come down either hard on the left
or hard on the right about the onion is
always satirizing from that perspective
on the left side you know making fun of
the gun rights people or something like
that
um and and you know we we're just doing
it from the other side and and kind of
firing back but but to call our motives
into question how do they know our
motives how do they know where we're
writing this satire to try to mislead
people it's silly our website is so
obviously a satirical website so
um we actually we sent him a demand
letter demanded that they retract that
story within five days they edited that
story they did and so they at least did
it yes they deleted all the references
to us in that story I think it's
important for the audience to know you
if they haven't heard about you guys you
got 20 million visitors a month I think
you've got 20 000 paid subscribers I
believe those numbers could be bigger
today yeah they're old numbers
it's not like you're not getting you're
getting a ton of traffic everyone's
talking about you guys right now you
guys are funny you're you're doing it
the right way when has satire ever been
canceled has there ever been a satire
Sideshow uh uh Talent that's ever been
canceled
well there's certainly been comedians
who have been canceled right there's
been comedians who have been attacked um
there's been the comedians who have lost
their Twitter pages or their Instagram
Pages for making jokes that were
considered Beyond The Pale Politically
Incorrect usually it's not for
misinformation it's unusual the way that
we're getting you know we get we got
caught up in this whole thing where uh
around the last election there was all
this concern about fake news influencing
voters right so Facebook Twitter they
were really concerned about the spread
of misinformation how it would lead
people to believe false things about the
candidates about what was going on and
so they wanted to clamp down on that and
control misinformation so they started
working with third-party fact Checkers
and they started fact checking stories
that were factually inaccurate and
writing them false yeah so they could
then flag them and let people know that
they were false or take them down and
completely pull them down they started
doing that with us so we got fact
checked uh the most notable one happened
the first big one that happened was in
2018 we wrote a piece about how CNN had
purchased an industrial-sized washing
machine to spin the news in before
publication which is pathetic you may
want to say that one more time and we're
going to put the picture up here for
people to see can you can you repeat
that CNN purchases industrial size
washing machine to spin the news in
before publication now it's absurd right
it's like that that can't actually
happen there's no real way to spin the
news that's a metaphorical thing it's
not a physical thing so so that the joke
is just silly on the surface but they
rated it false and then Facebook
threatened to de-platform and demonetize
us because of that joke so that's a
great example right there of the type of
action that's sometimes taken against uh
you know comedy sites or satiris
um it could be either because of
misinformation or because it's deemed to
be hate speech because you're making fun
of the wrong people did you see what uh
you saw what just happened with Dave
Chappelle recently yeah of course yeah
Dave Chappelle is you know you've got
people doing a virtual walkout at
Netflix it's been a story in the news
now for weeks yeah because he he made
comments and jokes that that people
didn't like so they're trying to get him
taken off Netflix they're trying to get
Netflix Netflix they're standing with
them they are standing with them which
is great which is impressive because
Reed Hastings is on the left and he gave
three million dollars to Newsome to help
save his recall so right it's not like
they fully agree with everything he's
saying it's just the business model
saying we're okay back in uh Chappelle
and leaving him on there right right
it's important I mean it's it's nice to
see liberals being liberal and actually
standing for free speech Bill Maher is
one of them I respect who is always
coming out against cancer culture did
you hear about what he said recently
uh it may have been in August like two
months ago where he's having a
conversation about how for the longest
time you know conservatives try to do
comedy and it never worked because uh
Pelosi is not that fun and he was
talking about Dennis Miller he says
Dennis Miller is a very good comedian
but the moment Dennis Miller became a
conservative and they had him do a
10-minute skit on Nancy Pelosi you just
can't do it he says but Sarah Palin
let's face it she's a I don't know if
you call her stupid [ __ ] something he
called her something like that and he
said but today things have flipped he
says today there's stuff they're writing
about and the stuff that the Liberals
are doing on the left it's officially
comedy there's officially comedy for
conservatives to have an SNL model to
make fun of the left because half the
stuff just doesn't make sense you're
making it easy for them it wasn't the
case 10 20 years ago right would you
have guessed a Bill Maher saying
something like that in 2021 a Bill Maher
who's been known as a guy on the left
yeah well you know he he what I respect
about him is he takes his own side to
town ask it's one of the things that we
try to do with our satire is make fun of
the you know we make fun of trump like
crazy and a lot of people that follow us
who are Republicans or conservatives who
like our humor because we align with
them politically they can't stand when
we make fun of trump but we do it anyway
because Trump deserves to be married
we did one on how uh some of the ones
that you read are some of our most
viewed it looks like you looked up ones
that have like the most page views or
shares uh we did one about how Trump
claimed to uh have done more for
Christianity than Jesus himself
and that was it was just a straight
quote from Trump trump I have done more
for Christianity than Jesus himself now
that's believable I find that believable
right because you're playing in Trump's
ego I could totally see him saying that
now we wrote that in 2019
you listen to this this is crazy we
wrote that in 2019. Snopes fact checked
it rated it false now the reason Snopes
fact checked is because it was going
viral people were sharing it believing
it was true to me now answer this for me
I'm going to interview you for a second
is if if people believe that story is
true is that an indictment of satire or
of trump
it's an indictment of him right that is
unbelievable but but the point is you
know if I read that article and I would
have said yeah after the 70th time of
saying there's no way he would say
something like that you're like you
probably would say something like that
yeah yeah it's believed caused that it's
believable it's believable because he's
got that outlined his personality he's
got a big ego it's believable now that
means that's good satire because satire
rides on the back of the truth right we
go in the direction the truth is
pointing exactly so I'm still laughing
thinking about it so now here's the
thing on I think it was like October 9th
what is it now it's we're in mid-october
right it's been a couple of weeks yeah
Trump came on a program doing an
interview because he said be quiet I
have done more for religion and
Christianity than any other person in
history he didn't say that two weeks ago
Trump said that
two weeks ago
so we made that joke in 2019.
What's the title of the uh the article I
have done more for Christianity than
Jesus himself okay go ahead I'm
listening to you yeah so uh so now
here's the interesting thing Snopes
rated it false but now he's actually
said it if you look it up you can
actually see he made that statement just
a couple of weeks ago three and a half
million 15 million shares this article
yeah yeah that one went crazy
[Laughter]
so now that he's actually on record
saying it Snopes might have to go back
and change that one to true because they
rated a false initially so and then the
article the way it reads I'm just going
to read this article so people kind of
have an idea Washington DC in response
to Christian today editorial column for
his remover Trump called the magazine a
left-wing Rag and said I have done more
for Christianity than Jesus I mean the
name of the magazine is Christianity
Today and who is doing more for
Christian Christianity Today not Jesus
he disappeared no one knows what
happened to him but I'm out there every
day protecting churches from crazy
liberals here's a part though let me
explain to you my experience with onion
okay
first time I want to say 11 years ago I
have no idea what the onion is I'm not
followed you know onion my friend Tom
sends me an article from onion okay
and I don't know what the article was
about I'm like Tom are you kidding me
when did this happen
and originally I believe the story right
right because I fell and says no Patrick
it's onion onion is a satire website
that does it so many if somebody reads
this for the first time yeah those are
the people's reaction you know how you
watch a movie with somebody and you want
to see their reaction for the first time
I want to see someone's reaction for the
first time who has no clue what Babylon
B is right to say did you hear about
this new side what they posted what
Trump said today and you share with them
just to get their reaction maybe I
should believe this stuff though a lot
do because it's believable and again I
have to make this point it's a very
important point the fact that satire is
believable see what they want you to do
when they don't like your jokes
the left was fine with this one because
it fed into their narrative that Trump
is you know an egotistical maniac and he
is braggadocious and whatever so they
didn't mind this one but when what what
they're trying to get you to do when
they don't like your jokes is they're
trying to say hey look you know people
are believing this stuff it reflects
poorly on us they want you to have jokes
that are so divorced from reality that
no one could possibly believe they were
true but have you heard the saying
there's a grain of Truth in every joke
or it's funny because it's true yes
right that's what makes comedy effective
is if it's if it's got a grain of Truth
in it it's rooted in the truth it's just
exaggerating a little bit for you know
hyperbole just to make a point so that's
what satire does so this is good satire
if it's believable people will try to
criticize it for that reason and say
this is you guys are misleading people
on purpose by publishing the stuff
that's believable no that's not that's
not how it works I think about my
friends I get listen for Armenians
Assyrians Persians man they're naturally
satire right they're naturally like this
they're very good at being sarcastic
telling jokes like this if it Armenians
watching this one of you guys has got to
do something with Babylon being for The
Armenian side anyways so tell me how you
come up with this like what is the
business model is it mainly are you guys
sitting in a creative room and everybody
pitches it's a lot of pitching pitching
pitching how do you guys come up with
these titles a lot of pitching yeah I
mean so we primarily were riding on the
back of whatever's in the news cycle
right so we want to be timely with it we
want to be writing about whatever people
are currently thinking and talking about
so uh we wake up in the morning and look
at the headlines read the headlines and
when I say we I mean my team it's not
it's not me personally for the most part
doing this I do pitch ideas but but we
have a whole team of writers who are uh
you know they're in the slack channels
pitching ideas it's all in the headline
right we start with the headline we
don't create the image we don't write
the article we write headlines and Pitch
them over and over and over again until
we get one that's right or we iterate on
it and you know we got like a seed
thought that's good but the headline's
not worded properly we'll you know keep
rewriting it tossing it back and forth
until we get it nail it and then once we
got the joke in the headline then we
hand it off get the photo to shop down
get the article written up and all that
so we pitch for every article we publish
there's probably 100 150 headlines
pitched
um no we're turned down that were turned
down that didn't go live how many go how
many every day how many did you guys
post every day
we probably published between five and
ten new articles a day depending on the
day and then we also repost some
Evergreen stuff from so only five to ten
a day so yeah not a lot of model is to
come up with the best five or ten a day
yeah yeah got it yeah you know people
can only handle so much satire in their
news feed and they're only going to
share so much satire so I don't think it
makes sense to have a model where like
Fox News we're publishing an article
every three minutes you know throughout
the course of the day there's just no
way to inundate people with it like that
it's not the right kind of content so
we're going for for quality over
quantity so how much is obviously I
would have to say the king of satire for
satire business is Trump he's got to be
at the top I don't right I would put him
at the top for who to satirize
yes now okay so this might be this it's
debatable but Trump on the one hand is
low hanging fruit right because if you
say he's not though he will uh he on the
one hand he's low hanging fruit because
he's like an outrageous personality
Biden kind of the same way he's he's you
know he mumbles this gibberish sometimes
he's hard to understand he says crazy
things he sniffs people's hair he does
weird stuff it's easy to make fun of
um
but
when you're exaggerating the truth to
make your point when the truth is Trump
is an exaggeration himself so you got
regular reality then you got Trump who's
like a crazy guy and then you got to try
to exaggerate him you're exaggerating an
exaggeration I find it more challenging
to parody that which is already a parody
of itself so Trump seems like a
character out of a movie already so I
think it's challenging to parody things
in fact I've uh I quote GK Chesterton
all the time he said back in 1911 the
world has become too absurd to be
satirized he said that over a hundred
years ago today we got crazy stuff
happening really crazy stuff happening
that actually makes the project of
satire more difficult because it's hard
to exaggerate something that's already
so exaggerated and and uh you didn't
answer my question so who would be at
the top who would be the goat to
satirize
um is it is it a bush is it a
like today there's people like I think
fauci is an easy one you know because
fauci's been kind of on every side of
these issues he said things that
contradict himself sure over and over
again so we've made jokes about how
fauci debates you know hit the five
previous versions of himself
um it's not hard to do when you're the
sexiest man alive like it's kind of
tough to do that right see that's funny
he's like been on the front of magazines
but he's like this elderly doctor it's
just the whole thing is just funny it's
bizarre unexpected
um so I think he's he's a good one I
think that the more outrageous the
personality like Trump the more
difficult it is but also when you just
nail it when you get it just right I
wrote a a piece a a headline about how
Trump went Twitter went down for a few
hours right
um and so I pitched a headline to the
team about how uh okay he can't tweet
because Twitter's down this is before he
got suspended like what would Trump do
what would Trump do okay let's do a
story about how he because Twitter's
down he went out on the balcony of the
White House and was just shouting his
thoughts to whoever was listening you
know so we did a piece about like during
Twitter outage Trump is out on the White
House balcony just shouting his thoughts
to like whoever's in earshot just to
whoever you know just because he has
nowhere no other outlet for it and it
was funny it got shared a ton of times
because it was kind of like kind of
believable but also pretty silly
um so for for those reasons Trump is fun
but it's it's really challenging to find
just the right angle on him gay man
miraculously turned straight by single
bite of Chick-fil-A
who comes up with that
San Francisco bans people from eating at
uh unsanitary in and out must eat on
poop-covered sidewalks instead have you
been to San Francisco that was two
months ago I know yeah that would be
it's a mess today liberal parents trying
to figure out how to cheer for his son
Brandon
is this this is this is a reason when
I'm assuming oh yes yeah yeah yeah
it was chanting for him it was very
inspirational when I saw that happening
it was in the NBC lady caught it right
so so right now like can anybody mess
with you guys today I mean after you
going back to New York Times and having
them change it did you was that
ultimately like your insurance policy to
protect yourself against them coming
back after you well so I want to do a
couple things with that like uh there's
there's a couple things for one for one
thing we I would prefer strongly to just
laugh this stuff off and joke about it
because that would be in character for
us right to just mock the New York Times
um but because of the way the social
networks treat misinformation and they
take it so seriously we lit we literally
just can't sit there and make jokes when
the New York Times is out there saying
that we are misinformation so we had to
make a statement about it and my Hope
was that we would set some precedent for
um showing these media companies and
these media personalities that when they
make false characterizations of us we're
going to actually do something about it
instead of just laugh it off so I think
there was some precedence set for that
with it with their retraction I think
it's less likely now that other media
companies will make that same mistake
which is good I think that was you know
a win for us we Notch that is a big win
um but it doesn't mean there aren't
other threats I think the main if you
could if you were to ask me right now
what I think the main threat is to
satire right now on like the social
media platforms it's this idea of
punching down you're familiar with
punching down
um and I can explain it for people who
are watching who may not be familiar
with that but but you have this new
policy that Facebook is rolling out
they've announced it recently I think
back in June um that they're going to
put together a policy specifically
around satire satire is allowed on
Facebook you can do it you just can't
punch down and what that means is you
can't make fun of people uh you can't
make jokes or make fun of people who are
below you it's hypocritical by the way
what punching down means
what do you mean like if for you're
punching that you can't say anything
about women why so you're saying women
are beneath me right exactly that's what
I punch you what are you punching down
that's what I said that's sexist ain't
it no that's punching down but you're
you're contradicting yourself yeah you
know with what they're coming up with
yes if I say if I look at a woman I say
you know what I'm not going to make a
joke about you because uh you're beneath
me and I would rather not joke about
someone who's beneath me that's you know
that's not polite what does that say
that's so condescending to look at
somebody and say I'm not going to joke
about you because you're beneath me now
what they try what they'll try to say is
that it's about power right like who has
the power the people who have the power
shouldn't be making jokes about the
people who don't have the power
um that's really what they're what
they're what they're trying to get at
there but they're they're putting people
into this hierarchy where you're in
these tiers and based on your score from
your race your gender uh you know your
status and privilege in Life or whatever
uh you get scored and tiered and there's
certain people that you just can't touch
you can't make fun of I reject the whole
thing for the reason you just gave I
think it's I think it's condescending I
think it's hypocritical I think it
reinforce and perpetuates sexism
misogyny racism Etc to think less of
people or to think that there are people
beneath you I think that if we're all
created equal and I believe that we are
then we should all be able to joke about
each other indiscriminately and not uh
and not be like hands off certain groups
um now does that mean being like taking
somebody while they're down being
malicious no but I see it as precisely
the opposite conservatives in my mind
being one myself conservatives are
really have been on the ropes in the
culture War for a long time we've been
on the defensive the left the
progressive ideas have been winning they
dominate education they dominate the
corporations they dominate media and
entertainment they dominate right now in
politics so you have Progressive ideas
that are dominating everywhere and cult
and cultural conservatives are really on
the defensive so when they make jokes
back in the other direction if anything
I would say they're punching up against
the institutional Powers not punching
down at people who are who are less
powerful or influential than they are
when's the last time conservatives were
winning all those areas though like
Winslow last time conservatives were
winning education universities politics
media uh you know when's the last time
they had it it's been a long time what's
a long time not in my lifetime what I'm
trying to wonder is if they ever had it
like you know in one sense like I'll
give you an idea Time Magazine is for
sale for 350 350 million dollars why
don't you buy it if you're on the right
why doesn't somebody who goes and buys
it Mark benihoff buys it Washington
posts for sale for a few hundred million
dollars you mean that's a lot of money
how many billionaires on the right can
go buy that right so many of them you
know you got LA Times is for sale for
550. I think Peter June bought it for
551 or 541 so no some number like that
that's nothing you could have bought it
late times how about if you would have
made an offer for a billion dollars
Forbes Magazine is owned by Forbes the
family right you know who they end up
selling to have you seen what's happened
with Forbes late it was always known as
protective of fiscally conservative
capitalists all this other stuff do you
know who owns Forbes Magazine today I
don't do you have any idea if I told you
right now I'm so curious to know what
your reaction will be I'm actually going
to show it to you so you see it here's
Forbes Wikipedia the only acquisition I
know of in that list was Bezos buying
the post okay so here's Forbes who owns
95 percent
integrated whale media China how the
hell does how do you sell to China how
does the number one business magazine
sell to China itself this is the part
where I think uh you gotta respect the
left because
were long-term thinkers but for you
since you're in the world I wonder maybe
maybe you had a different story where it
was a time where you know Cronkite even
was secretly on the left but he played
the position of Center and people
trusted him on what he would say he you
know and not Cronkite whatever he was
politically but he would stay Center so
you can kind of make a decision for
yourself we don't have that today when
did that change did it change because uh
we gamified TV did it change because
hosts were all gamified on who can get
the most views did it change because of
a Morton Downey Jr came and showed I
don't know if you remember Morton Downey
Jr he became so
crazy and wild and controversial that
all of a sudden he passed up Oprah
Winfrey Springer Montel and those were
all faces of TV and Morton came in 18
months he's number one on all these
platforms did that become inspirational
where all someone Beck is kind of going
that direction you know if MSNBC goes
that Direction with some of the stuff
Matthews was doing what flipped for
these guys to start winning well there's
a lot of things so I mean if you go back
in the history of religion for example
you know there's you had basically this
idea of like Theocratic Fascism and you
know religious groups that were trying
to control society and impose their uh
their morality on society and and make
sure everybody was abiding by their
religious principles basically you know
you've had that happen historically with
conservatism though when you get into
like politics generally speaking you
know conservatives Libertarians they
want to kind of uh They Want To Live and
Let Live and they're happy to have
people have ideological disagreement
with them and they they welcome the
debate and they welcome ideological
diversity the left one diversity of a
different kind the left wants diversity
of skin color and gender and
intersectionality you know they don't
want diversity of opinion and Viewpoint
so when they take over an institution
they lock it down they try to hold that
ground and and prevent people from
coming in even when you you know you
look at corporations that are
predominantly leftists in their in their
corporate makeup who they who they
donate to which kind of candidates they
donate to it's hard to even get into
these places if you're conservative it's
hard to get a job at at Facebook Google
you can't be publicly out about who you
are politically they don't want
diversity of viewpoint they want
diversity of other factors so the once
they gain that power it's very difficult
to rest it back from them and so I think
a lot of people on the right right now
are trying to create Alternatives
they're trying to create alternative
social media platforms daily wires
trying to create alternative media
release their own movies people are
trying to publish books for kids that
are coming from a conservative
perspective
yes they're uncanceling people who are
canceled other places good for Ben
Shapiro he's done the right thing Gina
Carano who got who got canceled from
Disney
they're doing a movie they're doing a
movie with her which is great that's
great it's not a big budget movie it's a
million and a half two million dollars
but if you give me the eyeballs and
they're putting it on the app I think
the number I got is 300 000 people
watched their uh movie they did on the
app whatever the movie is about the
shooter you know the 17 year old
Shooters run hide Fighters run height
fighting something like that yeah so
question for you so for me I'm in the
military
I'm an atheist I'm a Democrat when I'm
in the military and I was a registered
Democrat and atheist still 25. this is
what I was and and here's what I always
learned okay when I would watch people I
I had I always made fun of people who
were too square like too proper you know
what I mean where it's like well so what
are you doing this weekend well I'm
gonna go to church and then I'm going to
do this I'm like oh my gosh freaking
what a boring weekend you're gonna go to
church on it you have two days you you
got seven days five days we're in school
you got two days to yourself you're
gonna spend Sunday going to church
you're out of your mind that doesn't
make any sense what a boring guy you are
right so yeah a way of looking at that
thing about going to church you fall in
the score category because if you want
to party like let's look at this you got
the far left you got the conservative
you got the liberal you got the
libertarian okay if I put it in there
you got the independent in the middle
right okay okay if you probably want to
party and have fun
who are you going to have the most fun
with if you want to party get drunk get
hammered have fun no responsibility no
rules no regulation just screw off who
would you want to party with well it
depends on how you look at it I'd say
there's a lot of people if you go to
like a town if you go to like a town
like Nashville and you're hanging out
with a bunch of countries who are like a
lot of them are super Conservative
Christian Church calling people but
they're they'll throw back some beers
with you and party with you and have a
lot of fun Silverado I mean I want
Silverado every Saturday night exactly
yeah so I mean it depends now Nashville
can also be a pretty liberal town at
least it is in a uh from a governmental
perspective
um but I don't know is this a trick
question there's no short question here
no satire no trick I don't have a
follow-up the only reason I'm asking you
this is because I'm thinking about I'm a
businessman right so I run businesses
I'm thinking about it from marketing
standpoint how terrible of a job
conservatives have done pitching their
life right as being fun as like because
a life is like this well listen because
you want to save yourself because it's
the right thing to do and the drugs you
don't want to touch drugs because God Is
Watching it's so much like fear you know
what you can do now you've got to
remarket that storyline you can talk to
young people say young people like to be
rebellious right you know it's
rebellious now what's that get married
Young have kids raise a family take your
son fishing teach him to read teach him
values that's rebellious today that's
rebellious though the way they want you
to live now today the the the proper way
to to live is to find yourself and
explore and and do all this crazy stuff
and don't have any principles and who
cares what gender you are or who you're
who you're dating and who you're seeing
or how many you're seeing at the same
time like there should be no
restrictions uh the rebellious way to
live now is the way that's kind of that
straight and narrow path where it's
rooted in values and tradition
um you know I asked this question
because you got eyeballs right you you
have to win the young yeah younger
audience you don't win the younger
audience somebody's going to win the
younger audience over if you don't do it
right so so the left has what they have
most of sports I would say probably not
baseball I think they got football Maybe
baseball is 50 50. let's just say right
they definitely have NBA it's 95 right
minus a couple you know maybe a couple
guys from Orlando Magic or different
places but they have MBA you know NHL
Nobody messes with the NHL have you ever
noticed NHL and politics they just don't
touch them there's somewhere they're
going to whoop their ass they're like
listen we'll fight anybody else these
NHL guys are missing teeth I probably
don't want to mess with these guys
they'll find me at a bar and whoop my
ass but everything is marketing they
have the movies they have the nightlife
they have the social media they have the
education they have all of that so I
think the rebranding of the right so I'm
asking this only from the perspective of
whoever is here I okay so for example uh
uh one of the pastors invites me a month
ago and he says would you mind doing a
very big church this is a church that's
known linked to Billy Graham massive but
the marketing isn't that good
they have a meeting with me and the
senior pastor and I are working together
on marketing very closely okay but we're
working at Market they come to my house
once a month we have this meeting
together great
so how do we get this exposure out there
I said first of all because you know
Church attendance has been coming now
Christian Christian Church attendance
coming out typing is coming down you go
to a lot of churches we used to have 20
000 people here when you don't today you
only got 2200 and there's a big
difference between 2200 and 20 000 what
changed you're not marketable you're
boring you're still trying to convert
the ways of 50 years ago the way you
convert it the way you converted 40
years ago it's just not going to work
today you're still not allowing people
in that maybe are slightly more
different than you that are rebellious
that want to have conservative belief
but they got to fit in your box if they
don't fit in your box so if a guy like
me I went to a church and I went to 26
churches what I went to Scientology I
went to LDS Mormonism I studied
everything from God makers to Joseph
Smith to book of Moroni I went to Seven
Day Adventists I looked at Jehovah
Witness I looked at Los Angeles Church
of Christ that ended up being a cult I
looked at everything everywhere I would
go was too much about this right and
then one day I go to this one church and
sitting all the way in the back I'm like
every Christian Church I've gone to has
told me I'm going to hell this is the
first church I've gone to that maybe
maybe they'll let me stand in line to
have a spot in heaven I already know I'm
going to hell based on the life I've
lived maybe I got a spot in heaven who
knows right so guess what I do I stick
around a little bit and I like the guys
approach I'm like I think there's some
there's something here the guy's got 25
000 members today in L.A crushing it
Dudley absolutely crushing it in the
valley a big Liberal County he's got 25
000 people going to his church but I
think the approach that's taken in the
last 5 10 15 20 years maybe the reason
why they've lost it is because they left
adapted
and they didn't adapt well maybe the
reason that church is so popular is
because it's just telling people what
they want to hear rather than
confronting them with the truth I mean
and I'm not speaking to your situation
specifically but when when I think of
like what would resonate with young
people there's just this video that I
saw recently and forget who it was put
out by maybe it was like Heritage or
something or campus reform like this
young uh this college uh organization
and they interviewed college kids and
they asked them about it was about
affirmative action and you know
diversity and hiring and stuff like that
they're asking if if you know
affirmative action should be something
uh that not just happens at the
University but also at corporations
where people hire based on diversity
quotas to make sure that the makeup of
the company matches the makeup of the
community you know if the community is
40 black the makeup of the company
should be 40 black right and all the
students agreed and then they asked okay
well what about the sports teams what
about your team
if the makeup of the community is 80
white does the basketball team need to
be 80 white do we need to do that oh no
no that should be skill based that
should be skill based they all answer
the same they're like okay so with the
sports they want to win right they want
to win that's all they care about so
with sports they were really dead they
saw that it was better to be skill based
and talent based and rooted in that but
then when you ask them about like the
workplace and everything they were
completely fine with the diversity
quotas this interviewer got every single
person they interviewed all these
college kids to change their mind and
see that maybe the diversity quotas
aren't the best thing for companies or
sports teams if you want to win what
should really matter is the talent the
drive the ambition the skill uh it
should be it should be based on Merit
and not on your skin color for example
got to take that out of it and and it
convinced a lot of people to change
their minds I think it's just a matter
of presenting the truth in the right way
to young people young people are going
to be receptive to truth and I think in
our current day and age where we're
drifting so far away from truth and
everything is subjective and everybody
has their own truth I think that a lot
of people are going to become very
enchanted with that feel very
unfulfilled and unsatisfied with that
and they're going to really be craving
the truth but when it comes to like
entertainment and the right not doing it
right look I'm here sitting here as
evidence running I run right now the
most popular satire site on the internet
and it's a conservative publication we
are the most popular satire side on the
internet and we're run by conservatives
and have a largely conservative audience
I don't think you're following the
status quo though I don't think you I
don't think you're following the uh
status quo I don't think you're going
doing it the way they're doing it I
think you're crushing it because you're
so creative and I think the right has
forgotten that they need to get creative
they've been so much about you know how
sometimes you're married you're like
whenever you see marriage is like hey
same spots same bedroom same position
same restaurant same dinner same travel
same vacation same conversation just
like hey you're just kind of going seven
years later you look at a couple we go
to restaurants or my wife and I
sometimes I'll just look at dinner
different couples having dinner and I'll
say wow those guys have sat there for
six minutes haven't talked to each other
yet okay those stuff sat there and
they've been on the phone the entire
time for 15 minutes those guys are into
each other they're married and I'll go
up and I'll say I'm sorry how long you
guys been married together 25 years how
do you guys still enjoy each other's
company what's the secret sauce you
right right I think the conservatives is
just business as usual no more let me
get creative you're getting creative
well yeah I mean we're we are doing what
they do well we're doing it back and
that's what I was saying before it's
like it's it's this concept of punching
back they're very good at being creative
they're very good at mockery and
ridicule and and and I think bad ideas
bad behavior hypocritical Behavior
whatever needs to be mocked it needs to
be uh scorned and ridiculed especially
before like people young people start
adopting those ideas yes what's called
you say it's a powerful quote if you
don't mind sharing the C.S Lewis quote
Oh yeah or a good philosophy must exist
if for no other reason because bad
philosophy needs to be answered that's
right yeah I and I and I say this all
the time when I give talks on this or
interviews on this it's a bad satire is
necessary for the exact same reason that
good philosophy is necessary is to
confront those bad ideas it just does it
in a different way it does it with humor
sarcasm mockery irony but I think that
that is a very aggressive
um you know rather than being polite and
just saying oh you guys have a different
Viewpoint than we have here's our here's
the reason that we believe what we
believe what satire does is it
aggressively goes after those bad ideas
to try to tear them down and make them
look foolish and silly and expose them
for what they are and that's something
that historically the left has been
better at we're I think finding so much
success because we're doing it back in
the other direction I think it's great I
think that's the part where when I look
at these guys and I see were you a
strong Christian as a kid or no were you
yeah I grew up in a Christian family
yeah my dad's a pastor of a church uh
throughout my youth are you married I am
yeah how long you been married I'm
married 11 years kids two boys yeah
eight and five and and you look like
you're in your 30s though I'm 38 yeah 38
years old yeah so so you've lived in a
house with solid values strong values
you went through it uh uh and and being
a good citizen today with your eight and
five-year-old I'm married
I don't know how many years it is right
now 12 and a half years
was born on our anniversary date the
last one we have a nine-year-old an
eight-year-old a five-year-old
and nearly a four month old as well yeah
so it's non-stop with us but you know if
you now let let imagine the conservative
billionaires are watching okay they hire
you as a consultant you're a young guy
that's figured it out right you're doing
it right in your own way daily wire is
doing their part you doing your part you
got a couple of these guys that are
doing what they're doing to protect
their own uh uh values and principles
that they have what feedback would you
give to folks who are in the church who
are asking why are memberships down why
is attendance down why is the the
tithing and involvement down second if
you talk to some of these guys who are
I'm not talking about the Larry arms of
the world we've had Larry Arnon from
Claremont Institute Larry yarn I'm not
talking about those guys who are doing
their part with school education I'm
talking about some of the guys that are
sitting on the sidelines that are
wondering what can we do about it to get
more creative what feedback would you
give them well first of all I wouldn't
probably be a consultant for them
because I just make jokes on internet so
they'd be stupid to ask me but if they
did ask me I think that I think that
right now the left is creating a massive
Opportunity by going completely woke by
making all kinds of rules about what you
can do and what you can say you must be
vaccinated you must not make you must
use the proper pronouns you must not say
they try to compel speech they try to
compel thought they try to make certain
thoughts crimes certain words crimes and
they do that in entertainment areas
comedians are feeling that pressure we
talked about Dave Chappelle briefly
Chappelle's feeling that pressure but
here's the thing we're talking about
Chappelle and he's getting more views
than anybody else the people who are
willing to make the jokes you're not
supposed to make and say the things
you're not supposed to say are going to
have a massive massive audience because
that majority they call it like the
silent majority that got Trump voted
right there was always like people were
wondering where's all the support for
Trump come from there were a lot of
people who were like holding that in and
not talking about their support for
Trump until they got to The Ballot Box
and they voted for him there's a lot of
people in this country a huge huge huge
percentage of people in this country who
reject all of that kind of uh uh control
and they just want personal Liberty they
want personal freedom They Want To Live
and Let Live
and they want real comedy they want
people to be able to joke about things
anything and nothing off limits you know
and just and actually engage in real
conversation and entertainment that's
not watered down with all the things
you're supposed to say and supposed to
do so I think okay so what daily wire is
doing is a great model they're taking
people who've been canceled like Gina
Carano and I don't know the name of the
ESPN personality
um they're gonna you're gonna continue
to see people do this where they gobble
up the canceled people and serve those
people right back to an audience uh
that's even bigger than the one that
they had before I think that that's
going to be a winning model in the
future especially as uh as you try as
they as they basically try to create
ideological conformity in all of these
areas people are going to push back on
that I think they're going to push back
hard that creates Market opportunity in
my opinion I agree Allison Williams is
her name by the way from ESL who left to
go there she was with them for I think
10 or 11 years yeah you said something
very important earlier uh that we just
kind of went to the next subject is when
I said the whole thing thing about you
know who you want to party with out of
these three and you know you got the
left you got the liberal you got the
libertarian you got the conservative to
me when I look at this I think if you
want to hang out with guys and go shoot
a bunch of things and hang out with
military guys probably libertarian right
you want to smoke weed you want
Libertarians yeah if you want to go hang
out with guys that are you're going to
feel safe and you're going to be able to
entertain ideas maybe go hang out with
Independents you know if you want to
have your kids learn maybe you know safe
values principles in an environment
maybe you're going hunting fishing yeah
so you want to go you know a part of
your ass off and be around guys I want
to break the rules and all this stuff
maybe you go with liberals if you want
to go uh have a headache maybe go hang
out with lefts you know you have you
have areas you can make if you want to
go save some trees or or pick garbage
out of the ocean or something like that
I don't even think that's it I don't
even think they realize what the hell
they're saying have to tell like what
are you talking about like it it blindly
following a political party over your
country is absolutely naive and stupid
blindly just because you're like oh I'm
supposed to do this oh because I'm this
okay I got to support it no you don't
right you got a question to say maybe
this is not a good idea maybe this is
not something you ought to support and
sometimes your own party will come up
with bad ideas but you said something
and here's what it was you said maybe
the way to sell being a family guy today
having the kids doing it the right way
is a form of rebellious because you are
rebelling against what they're making
seem the norm to be right where you have
to Market that hey you know the other
thing I would also add is the final one
like here's what I would add to that
which again you you use the word must
right you must get that that finish the
sentence with whatever you want to add
to it right vaccinated you must go there
you must follow everything that's not
mandatory is banned it's either
mandatory or it's banned makes no sense
to me right but to to to me as a rebel I
would sit there and said I must no no
it's not how this works no no I I
escaped Iran so I don't have to do all
like you know they everything there is
you must you must you have to you have
to you have to and you have to bow down
constantly no no we left there so we
don't have to so I get to pick and
choose the kind of a life I want to live
and if I get a speeding ticket which I
got one the other day very annoyed
because I got a I got a 32 mile an hour
speeding ticket and it was like 20 miles
he gave me I'm like why would you wait I
have a Ferrari I'd love to go 150 and
get a speeding ticket I don't want to
waste a speeding ticket on 32 right so I
get a 32 I was so annoyed all that was
annoyed I'm like I don't want to get a
speeding ticket at 32. honestly I feel
embarrassed even sure wait a minute 32
over the speed 32 miles an hour not even
32 miles over okay just 32 miles an hour
in a 20 they gave me a speeding ticket
but if I break the rule break the law
give me a ticket right but if you create
so many laws that I feel like you're
suffocating me right it's just a little
too much and I think that's the climb
you know how you ever watch your friends
maybe they had a parent
at one of my friends who's dad the guy
would go like this hey
he'll go like this he was like like dude
I couldn't do it around you I'd be
suffocating if I was around you right I
think today
politicians today are like that parent
that is not allowing you to make your
own mistakes like as if they know what's
right for you so maybe the way to reach
young people is to present to them here
here's what you can do with freedom
right we offer freedom and Truth we
stick to we think two plus two equals
four you know we hold two we hold to
that gender is rooted in your biological
sex uh you know basic facts of biology
that you learn in first grade that's
what we affirm uh we affirm Freedom you
know vaccines are good they do good
things but we shouldn't mandate them uh
it's your personal choice whether or not
you'll get one you know like those types
of things I think are speaking to young
people and I think young people are
jumping on to that I've seen people
personally we had a nanny that worked
for us a while ago she was younger uh in
her 20s by mid-20s uh very liberal on a
lot of things and has taken a total turn
in the other direction uh over this
whole uh covid stuff you know the the
lockdowns and the masking and she's got
young ones and she doesn't want her
little baby's mask and the vaccine
mandate she's fine with vaccines but she
doesn't want to be mandated and she's
seeing all this stuff and she's changed
her mind so I think a lot of young
people especially young people that are
at the age where they're starting
families are going to see a lot of value
in that
had a blast having you all men this was
great yeah very good to be spending time
with you uh we're gonna put the link
below to your site and specifically I'm
going to put the link below to the quote
Trump gave yeah about the fact that he's
done more for Christianity than uh Jesus
and look up his real quote where he
actually said David make a note to have
both of those maybe if you can show it
to him afterwards so you can put the
link of both of them below sure but
having said that my thanks for coming on
this was great thank you so much great
conversation yes absolutely thank you
really enjoyed the interview with them I
think satire is very necessary today if
you agree give it a thumbs up and
subscribe to the channel and if you
enjoyed the interview with Seth Dylan I
think you can enjoy the interview with
gatsad that I did it was funny
entertaining and I think your brain's
also going to have a work yet if you've
not seen that click over you to watch it
take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]